order i call secretary brandon lewis to
make a statement
secretary of state thank you mr speaker
i would like to make a statement on the
findings of the bala murphy inquest
i want to put on record the government's
acknowledgement of the terrible hurt
that has been caused to the families
of francis quinn father hugh mullen noel
phillips
joan connolly daniel teget joseph murphy
edward dougherty john laverty
joseph call and john mccur
i also want to pay tribute to the great
patience with which these families have
conducted themselves during their
determined
campaign which has lasted for almost 50
years
the prime minister is writing personally
to the families and expresses deep
regret to the first and deputy first
ministers of northern ireland yesterday
and has apologized unreservedly on
behalf of the state
the findings of the coroner are clear
those who died
were entirely innocent of wrongdoing the
events of bala murphy
should never have happened the families
of those who were killed should never
have had to experience the grief
and trauma of that loss they should have
not had to wait nearly five
decades for the judgment this week nor
have been compelled to relive that
terrible time
in august 1971 again and again
in their long and distressing quest for
truth
over the course of the troubles more
than three and a half thousand people
were killed
and tens of thousands injured with
families torn apart forever
the majority of those killed were
innocent civilians like those on the
streets
of bala murphy the vast majority of
those who served in northern ireland
did so with great dignity and
professionalism but it is clear
that in some cases the security forces
in the army
made terrible errors too the duty of the
state
is to hold itself to the high standards
at all times
when we fail to meet these high
standards we must recognize the hurt
and the agony caused there is no doubt
that what happened on those awful few
days in valor murphy
also fueled further violence and
escalation particularly
in the early years of the troubles the
government profoundly regrets and is
truly sorry for these events
and how investigations after these
terrible events were handled
and for the additional pain that the
families have had to endure in their
fight to clear the names of their loved
ones
since they began their campaign almost
five decades ago
to make lasting change actions are
required as well
the belfast good friday agreement was
the defining action
that allowed northern ireland to begin
to move away from violence
but the events of the past do continue
to cast a long shadow
as we have seen those who were killed
and injured during the troubles came
from all communities
and also included many members of the
security forces and the armed forces
immense and difficult compromises have
been made on all sides
since then including the early release
of prisoners which was so difficult
for many people to accept to a very
large extent
northern ireland has moved away from
violence
so we stand by those compromises and the
progress made towards a more peaceful
society
yet the desire for families families of
victims
to know the truth about what happened to
their loved ones is strong
legitimate and right the campaign for
justice in bala murphy has reminded us
all of this if we needed to be reminded
at all
twenty three years after the signing of
the belfast good friday agreement
thousands of murders remain
unresolved and many families still yearn
for answers
with each passing year the integrity of
evidence and the prospects of
prosecution do diminish
and the government is not shrinking away
from those challenges
we are determined to address them in a
way that reflects the time that has
passed the complexity
of northern ireland's troubled history
and the reality of the compromises that
have already been made
but above all we are determined to
address it in a way that enables victims
and survivors to get to the truth
which they deserve we must never ignore
or dismiss the past
learning what we can we must find a way
to move beyond it
and the corners findings this week are
part of that very often painful process
mr speaker this government wants to
deliver a way forward in addressing the
legacy of the past in northern ireland
one that will allow all individuals or
families who want information to seek
and receive answers about what happened
during the troubles
with far less delay and distress
we want a path forward which will also
pave the way for wider
societal reconciliation for all
communities
allowing all the people of northern
ireland to focus on building a shared
stable peaceful and prosperous future
i commend this statement to the house